you
hello and welcome from the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences where we've just
heard who is receiving 2008 Nobel Prize
in Physics to discuss this prize in more
detail I've been joined by professor
pair carlson member of the physics prize
committee there's some Carlson thank you
very much for joining us so she not
announce has being made could we begin
by you telling us whose receiver 2008
prize in physics when the hills are a
prize in physics has been divided in two
parts the first one is given to your
feeder number for the discovery of the
mechanism of spontaneous broken symmetry
in subatomic physics it's a difficult
name and difficult declaration and it's
not easier for the other tool that share
the second drive named it makoto
kobayashi and proceeded masada for the
discovery of the origin of the broken
symmetry which predicts the existence of
at least three families of warps but so
it's as you say it's quite a complicated
matter but in a nutshell the surprise
that celebrates the basic constituents
of matter and the phrase symmetry
appears on both the citations and that's
a phrase that might be unfamiliar to
people outside the world of particle
physics could you in simple terms
describe what symmetry actually means
wouldn't come down to the basic
constituents of matter
well I think the most the most obvious
thing is to explain that we are all here
in the universe the universe as we see
today is made up of matter no ultimately
we know our solar system is matter we
know all close by galaxy's and so on are
made of matter as normal and commands
nevertheless in the Big Bang to the
equal amounts of matter and anthem
just great
why why was there a symmetry that made
matter to dominate over and
because when matter and antimatter on I
alive they just disappeared so that that
is the violation of a symmetry which is
CP violation and that is part of the of
this year's discovered and when we talk
about a violation of symmetry we meaning
a slightly unequal amount of something
compared to something else in terms of
particle physics what is that something
we're talking about well let me turn to
the price to Kobayashi and mascara
because they saw more that they could
incorporate this by negative selection
only if ever three families of forms so
they predicted can you say that there
should be a third family of G walks
which was later discovered and also in
this last family of probes they can be
produced that new types of accelerators
which has been done quite recently
artist
the paper of mosca wakabayashi dates
back to nineteen seventy-two i believe
and certainly the recent findings are
from the 90 so taken some time so what
you're saying is that there was a there
was slightly more of a particular family
of quarks that was predicted by in libya
kobayashi and masala and that that
explains why there was slightly more
matter than antimatter in the universe
beginning from the Big Bang and explains
why we're here right now I think I think
I think that's correct well that there
are still open questions in this and the
question of broken symmetries for
instance we believe that there should be
a symmetry breaking which makes mark
tickets which gives masses to borrow why
why is it proton so much heavier than
the electron why is it I mean all they
state that exist why do they have
different masses but we don't know but
we believe there is a mechanism which
has to do with the broken symmetry which
gives most and that that mechanism
creates the Higgs particle which we hope
to see very soon
you